sin noticias de sus hijas secuestradas
en la noche del jueves al viernes
hombres armados irrumpieron en este
internado dejé nieve en el estado de
zamfara y secuestraron a 317 alumnas de
secundaria los enfrentamientos entre los
asaltantes y las fuerzas de seguridad
fueron violentos y se han escapado uno
de ellos abandonó su moto en la huida
fue entonces cuando pensamos que íbamos
a detenerlos luego nos dijeron que
volviéramos a casa y ahora mientras
hablo
los soldados están luchando contra ellos
en el mundial el gobierno federal envió
allí fuerzas fuertemente armadas y
actualmente inspeccionan la zona el
presidente mohamed dibujar y ordenó la
operación y anunció que no cederá ante
el chantaje ni pagará al rescate las
autoridades locales han anunciado el
cierre de todos los internados de la
región hasta nuevo aviso y acusan al
gobierno central de no proteger
suficientemente a sus ciudadanos
walt whitman
apreciamos los esfuerzos del gobierno
federal en la lucha contra los vándalos
y otras actividades delictivas en el
estado y deseo solicitar un mayor apoyo
en la lucha contra este desafío
combaten de esta ley
por el momento se desconoce la identidad
de los secuestradores en la zona operan
varias bandas armadas las familias
lloran a sus hijos desaparecidos una
escena cada vez más habitual en el norte
de nigeria en diciembre pasado encantará
a más de 200 kilómetros de distancia 300
adolescentes fueron secuestrados durante
la noche y liberados poco después los
secuestros masivos son motivados para
obtener lucro a través de los rescates y
en ocasiones vinculados a los yihadistas
de boko haram